بدات الهيئه السعوديه للملكيه الفكريه
بالشراكه مع وزاره التعليم تنفيذ مشروع
ادراج موضوعات الملكيه الفكريه في المناهج
والمقررات الدراسيه في مراحل التعليم
العام والذي تسعى من خلاله الى تطوير
القيم اللازمه لتمكين الطلاب من مهارات
التفكير الابداعيه والابتكار اضافه الى
تنميه سلوكيات الحفاظ على الحقوق المعنويه
والماديه للمبدعين والتعزيز الوعي بقواعد
الملكيه الفكريه وضوابطها
من رياض ينضم الينا رئيس تنفيذ الهيئه
السعوديه للملكيه الفكريه الدكتور عبد
العزيز السويلم دكتور عبد العزيز حياك
الله معي في نشره الرابعه
اول ماذا يعني هذا المشروع همم
ادراج موضوع الملكيات الفكريه همم في
المناهج والمقررات الدراسيه كيف سيتم ذلك
والحقيقه هذا يعني بالضروره ان المملكه
تؤكد على ما بدات في رؤيه 20 30 الاستثمار
الانسان والاستثمار في الانسان خلال رؤيه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
يؤكد على ان يجب ان نبني الاجيال بحيث ان
تكون اجيال قادره على الابداع والابتكار
قادره على معرفه الحقوق حمايه الحقوق
وايضا الاحترام
هذا ما يعمل عليها هذه المشروع بالشراكه
مع الزملاء وزاره التعليم للتاكد عند
الطلاب والطالبات في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
الملكيه الفكريه في المناهج المقررات
الدراسيه يعني
يمكن احد يقول لك انه الطلاب مع هذه
الزيادات وضع الكثير من المواضيع مش
ناقصين مواضع جديد
هو الحقيقه هناك عامل مهم جدا في البناء
على همم يتم الانتاج
اذا ارادت المملكه العربيه السعوديه من
خلال رؤيته ثلاث ايام التبني على ابداعات
المواطنين والتكاراتهم بحيث انك تتحول الى
منتجات قابله للاستثمار الصناعي يجب ان
يجب ان ينتجين يعرف معنى الابتكار يعرف
كيف يستطيع ان يحول افكاره الى منتجات
يعرف كيف يجعل هذه المنتجات الذات اكثر
تنموي اقتصادي على المستوى الوطني
وبالتالي تصبح قدره المملكه العربيه
السعوديه على ان تكون قدره ابداعيه
ابتكاريه منتجه المسارات العلوم والتقنيه
والتكرار وغيرهم المسارات الابداعيه
وزاره التعليم على التاكد ان ابجديات
ومبادئ
تنميه الافكار وحمايتها سيكون لها اثر
كبير جدا على ابنائه وبناتنا في مدارس
تعتمد عليها في تنفيذ هذه الفكره
هناك ماده اسمها ماده
العربيه للعلوم الرياضيه التربيه البدنيه
والتربيه الفنيه واللغه الانجليزيه
نعرف كيف يمكن ان عندما نقتل التفسير لهذه
الايات نشير الى المراجع بشكل صحيح نعلم
الطلاب عندما يرجع من خلال ماده همم
همم الرقميه كيف يستطيع ان يرجع الى
المواقع الصحيح ويشير الى هذه المواقع
بشكل سليم ههه كيف تستطيع الماء همم
الطالب ان ياخذ هذه الافكار ويلمي الافكار
وينقلها من مرحله الفكره الى مرحله
الابداع حاله التصنيع كل هذه مبثوثه في
مراحل التعليم بحيث المباد الملكيه
الفكريه تكون قدمت الشرارات في جميع
المراحل التعليميه وفي جميع المواد
التعليميه يكون اثرها التراكمي على طريقه
الطالب
طريقه الطالب الاحترام ذاته وقدره على ان
يكون مبتكر يكون قدره عاليه جدا عند
بينافس
حاله يمكن همم
موازيه للمعلم اللي قدم مثل هذه الموضوعات
والمواد وهذه المضامين هل لديكم اي برامج
لتطوير المعلمين ايضا اللي طرق تعليم
الملك الفكريه والتفاعل معه بشكل صحيح
يعني احنا بالفعل بدانا في تدريب عدد كبير
جدا من معلمين فوق بعض المجادل متعلقه
الفكريه خرجنا الدفع الاولى ايضا من معلمي
الملكيه الفكريه القادرين على تدريب في
مسارات الملكيه الفكريه تم تطوير مع
المنظمه العالميه الملكيه الفكريه برامج
متخصصه للمملكه في مسارتهم مرتبطه
توافق مع الانظمه المعمول بها في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وايضا ممكن تم تطوير
اكاديميه الملكيه الفكريه في الهيئه
السعوديه الفكريه اذا معن هذه الاكاديميه
تقدم الدعم والمسانده للمعلمين وايضا
لمطور المناهج التعليم
هي كان فكره من عندكم انتم ولا في دراسات
لدول اخرى كانت تستفيد من مثل هذا الناهج
او النادي المنهجيه في في التعليم سريع
والحقيقه يعني المملكه من اوائل الدول
التي ساعدت الى البث مواضيع الفكري في
جميع المناهج التعليميه نعم هناك
سنغافوره وفي بعض الاخرى بالاضافه الى
المنظمه عالميه تدعم مثل هذه التوجهات
والمملكه الحمد من اوائل الدول التي ساعد
الى البث المناهج
الدراسيه معينه ولا بشكل عام
ان شاء الله ينعكس حلو عليك
شكرا جزيلا لك الرئيس تنفيذ السعوديه
للملكيه الفكريه الدكتور عبد العزيز